passing the phone to somebody who can't
get acrylic i'm passing the phone to
somebody that doesn't let me do anything
wait i'm passing the phone to my
boyfriend
i'm passing the phone to someone with a
tampon in his nose
kourtney kardashian and travis barker
are making it a family affair
on tick-tock i'm passing the phone to
somebody who talks 24
7.
passing the phone to somebody who wiped
out while snowboarding and can't walk
i'm passing the phone to someone who
can't get off a ski lift
the reality star and musician took on
tick tock's past the phone challenge
with their kids
the video was posted to travis's
daughter alabama's account on thursday
and in it we see her brother landon
barker
as well as courtney's kids penelope and
rayne disick
i'm passing the phone to somebody who
can't get acrylics i'm passing the phone
to somebody that doesn't let me do
anything
wait i'm passing the phone to my
boyfriend
i'm passing the phone to someone with a
tampon in his nose the blink 182
drummer's step daughter atiana de la
hoya
also joined in on the fun i'm passing
the phone to somebody who's on their
second hair dye fail
i'm passing the phone to someone whose
nails are so long they can't wear ski
gloves
during the video landon playfully teases
courtney for her commitment to fashion
i'm passing the phone to somebody who's
changed their outfit
five times today i'm passing the phone
to somebody who's
ugh the families are hardly strangers to
viral social media moments
earlier this week alabama gave her dad a
makeover by covering his face tattoos
just blend it right into your skin so
where's your first tattoo back
my first tattoo was on my leg which
one's your favorite tattoo
probably the one we discovered
and on wednesday courtney and penelope
took on the
is it bus and janelle trend on tick tock
yesterday we got a bell pepper sandwich
let me show you how i made mine
janelle is it busting or what yo moms
how's the food
and when it comes to courtney's love
life she and travis turned their
longtime friendship
into something more earlier this year
the musician opened up about why their
relationship works during a march
appearance on the drew barrymore show
i would you know like date girls that
didn't have kids and i find it kind of
hard because they would i think they
would have trouble understanding like
well why
why don't you want to go to dinner every
night with me or why don't you want to
see me every night
and now i'm
you know spending time with a woman
who's like a great mom who's
like a great friend and i just
you don't have to worry about any of
those things it just comes natural it's
like a maturity thing
and last month travis's ex-wife shaina
mokler
whom he shares landon in alabama with
opened up to e.t about his new
relationship
and what it means for their co-parenting
dynamic
as long as she's good to my children
this is the the biggest point that i
keep saying and my kids like her my kids
do like her
that's all i care about you know my kids
are happy they're happy
they just said that she's really sweet
and she's she's really nice to them
um i i know she's given them a lot of
gifts as well
um that i i know that they love and
appreciate and
um you know as long as they're happy we
do share that
common thread of putting our kids first